not all I think we all want to live in a
world that is green I mean none of none
of us want to live in a polluted cities
or live global warming and I think the
good news is that the newly developing
countries is committed to the green
movement as the West is interior this
enough but of course in practice that
global warming for example if you want
China and India to reduce their flows of
new greenhouse gas emissions then then
the West must take responsibility for
the stock of greenhouse gas emissions
that the West has put up in the
atmosphere since the Industrial
Revolution but you don't take
responsibility for the stock and you
only go to txt the new flows they come
on they're gonna say China need is a
come on that's not fair you're not
putting an economic price on what you
put up and you're putting economic price
and what I am putting up and I'd much
poorer than you come on let's be fair
about this so I think if the West can
accept responsibility for what it has
done do you know create global warming
that in China and India will join the
bargain too
well i think that the good news is that
when you in your late comer you don't
have to pick all technology you can
switch to new technology i mean the good
news for example japan as you know is
one of the most energy-efficient
countries in the world indeed for every
additional unit of GNP that is created
china china spends ten times the energy
that Japan does but if you can create
technology transfer from japan to china
and it is happening by the way you can
progressively reduce the amount of
energy consumption that china does for
every additional unit of GNP so i think
it can be done and you can avoid the old
steel mills very polluted and new steel
mills less polluted all these things can
be done